Bởi các giữa ăn chứ thị công thành phủ yêu cầu ban khoa lý dự án đầu từ xây dựng công trình và các chủ đồ tự
thử phía trì đạo đơn vị từ vấn khảo xa đề đủ số liệu để chết để giữa giải pháp vị thoát
só sáng lợi trọng phương, ăn, tôi yêu về kinh tế kỹ thoát, nhằm tận dụ tối đa của nền tự nhiên
Đơn vị thị công không được phép đạo bỏ lấp nền cố khi chưa có sải pháp giáp của nền,
từ kiện gia của đất đạo từ công trình để tận dụng làm đất sân nền, đất đất nền, làm mống đường cho chính dự án nền chịn khai
chẳng thất loạn phí, đối với các giữa ăn sắp và đáng thị công thành phủ yêu cầu trong dự đạn giải pháp mặt bằng
phải xử li, đại chiếc thị gián ngay tải công trường, nếu có mặt bằng,
các chủ đối tức tận dụng sản phẩm và lượng đánh chế cho việc xan lấp đất nền, làm mống công trình,
sẵn nông nha vào môi trường đường xa chủ trì đánh ngay tính độ các giữa ăn xử li cho thị gián xây dự
đánh chín khai theo quy định. Chị thị đường bán hành trưng bối cảnh thành phố đất chín khai giải pháp mặt bằng
chân một nghiệm muốn chăm 20, là mặt pháp xin phay thải xây dự, các bạn hình đến 30,000 tấn mỗi ngày,
trong đó khoảng chí mới phần chăm là bởi vì lượng vô cơ có thể gái chế.
Khối lượng phay thải xây dự, các bạn hình pháp xin lượng trong việc công táp phân loạn tạnh 1,
chưa được đồng bộ. Tóa thành phố mơ có hai địa điểm tập két xử li chính.
Thành phố còn thiệu quy hoạch tổng thể và quy định của li bắt bộ. Theo cơ chế chính xa yếu đại tuốt đồng cơ,
và chưa hình thành phị trường tiêu thủ và liệu tài chế. Tình chẳng đồ chọn phía thải xây dựng còn gì mình
tức tập ở của bật phen lo, vên sông cây mơ đất công, gây ôn nhấn mơ chường,
anh hưởng tự mi quân đô thị và lắng xíu ngon tật liệu có thể tài chế.